-Having a teenage daughter is
like having an office crush
because you're just, like,
always, like --
You're thinking about them
a lot more
than they're thinking about you.
[ Laughter ]
And you just, like,
go up to their door
and you're like, "A bunch of us
are going to eat dinner.
You're probably busy."
[ Laughter ]
"You probably don't
want to do that."
Like, "Some of us thought
it would be cool
to, like, put a movie --
Never mind. Never mind."
And they just look at you
like --
They're looking at their phone,
like...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-♪ Best friends challenge ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-Now the game works like this --
I know.
There's you, and your
real best friend is Amy.
We love her. We know it.
She's the best.
This game works almost like
"The Newlywed Game,"
but for friends.
-Okay.
So we're gonna take turns
reading questions
about each other
from the Best Friends Box,
and we'll try to write down
the same answer.
We didn't plan any of this out.
I don't even know
how we're gonna do.
-I don't even know how to read,
so this is...
-Alright.
Here we go.
I will read the first question,
okay?
-Okay.
-"If Jimmy" -- I...
If I could have any other job
in the world, what would it be?
Do you know this about me?
-Uh, what you would choose?
-Yeah.
Oh, that's interesting.
-Uh...
-Yeah, what I would choose.
-Okay.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Okay.
-Alright.
You're still writing, okay.
-I'm still writing.
You don't have
to draw your answer.
[ Both laugh ]
-Okay.
Alright.
Tina, what did you write?
-So I show you? Okay.
So, what I --
I have two answers.
So one is what I think
maybe something
you used to be interested in.
I don't remember.
And the other's what
I think you should be.
-Okay. Gotchu, gotchu.
-So, my first answer is,
I think you would have been,
like, a graphic designer
or something, maybe.
I can't remember
what you studied
in that two weeks that
you went to college.
[ Laughs ]
And then what
I thought you should be
would be a Patch Adams
but just as an ambulance driver.
Like...
Like, an ambulance driver
who tries
to heal you with jokes.
Tries to heal you with jokes.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I said I want to be a mailman.
-Ohhh!
-I think they're great.
Anyway...
-It's a good choice.
-Yeah. Thank you.
Okay.
Now you read this one here.
Yeah. So, so far, we're 0-1,
Best Friends Challenge.
-Okay.
"If Tina" -- That's me...
-Uh-huh.
-"...was a breakfast cereal..."
-Mm-hmm.
"...which would would she be?"
[ Dramatic music plays ]
-If you were a cereal.
Not what is
your favorite cereal.
-Yeah. If I were a cereal.
-If you were a cereal.
-Okay. I'm trying to guess
by the sound of your marker.
-[ Laughs ]
That's a long...
It's like a prescription cereal.
-Well, I thought
this one really --
-Well, I thought this one
through.
-Okay.
-'Cause I was gonna say --
Well, if I say Cocoa Puffs,
that means
you're crazy or not crazy.
-Right.
Cheerios --
You are a happy person,
but I would say you're cheery.
I don't see you coming home,
like, "Hi, everybody!"
You know, like, you're...
NPR-ios, I could say that,
if that was a breakfast cereal.
-NPR-ios.
-That is not a cereal.
-Wheaties, I was gonna say
'cause it's classic,
and it's the breakfast
of champions.
-Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
-But instead, I went with...
Frosted Mini-Wheats.
-That's a good choice.
-Because -- You know why?
I thought about this.
One side gets the job done,
is pretty serious.
-Party in the front.
-[ Laughs ] And then...
Party in the front,
and then fun in the back, man.
-Colon health in the back.
-[ Laughs ]
-Party in the front.
-Colon health in the back.
No, it's, like --
No, the back is sweet.
It's fun and sweet.
-Thank you.
That's a big compliment.
-And it's very mini,
like you are.
-Ah, thank you.
-Yeah, you're tiny.
-I think this should be
counted as the same,
because I made up
a joke cereal name,
but I called them
Corn Blasters.
-[ Laughs ]
-'Cause it's something, like,
sweet and tasty, but also,
we're gonna go to the toilet.
[ Laughter ]
We're gonna get it done.
-That's it.
It's sort of the same thing.
-I think that -- That counts.
-That one counts.
Judges!
[ Ding! ]
Thank you.
That one counts.
Alright.
Here we go.
This is good.
We're winning.
We have one more here. Ready?
-What happens
if we're not best friends?
We're still friends, right?
-Yeah. Yeah.
We're always gonna be friends.
Yeah, we're still -- Please.
You're my favorite.
Okay. Oh.
What was our favorite joke
on "Weekend Update"?
I think I know.
-[ Exhales deeply ]
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-Pbht!
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Both chuckle ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Ah.
Okay.
I -- [ Sighs ]
-Okay. The music ran out.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
I wrote one --
I wrote one as a joke
and then one --
I think this is a real joke.
It was our favorite joke
on "Weekend Update."
Okay. I would say one is --
I put out hair,
because we had a lot of hair.
A lot of our bad hairstyles.
-[ Gasps ]
But then Fabergé egg.
Jesus autographs
and Fabergé eggs
was the punchline.
-Yes, that was the punchline.
It was like, the price of...
Somebody invented a car?
-That cost a lot --
Like, something cost
a lot of money, right?
-A car that runs on hazelnuts.
-Oh, right. Right, right.
That's right.
-And we went go,
"Oh, that's a great idea.
Hazelnuts are $9 a pound."
-Right.
I got a great idea.
-Yeah.
Let's make a car that runs
on Jesus autographs
and Fabergé eggs.
[ Laughter]
That's good.
-That was great.
-I delivered it.
You wrote it, I think.
-I think that was
an Adam McKay punchline.
-Gosh darn it,
that made me laugh.
-Oh, those were
the good old days. Okay.
I didn't get it exactly right.
I had two things.
Number two was sort of
an inside joke,
was that Tracy Morgan,
when he would do
"Update Features" --
-I already know what
you're gonna say.
-What am I gonna say?
-He always called me Jim.
"Jim! Jim!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
'Cause it would say
on the cards --
It would always say, like,
"Thank you, Jimmy,"
and he would always
come up and be, like,
"Thank you, Jim."
-Yeah.
-And it was just to mess
with you, right?
"She's in my dressing room,
Jim."
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
And then the number one I had
was one that you
kept doing so much
that you eventually got
in trouble for,
which was something was like,
this thing -- something dropped.
Like, the stock market
or something --
I think something went down,
and you're like --
Do you know what I'm gonna say?
Oh, it dropped more than...
-Someone's testicles
or something.
[ Laughter ]
-Martin Landau's testicles.
-There you go.
[ Laughs ]
-Martin Landau's balls.
-That is a good joke.
-And you --
-Yeah, alright.
That's good right there.
We're still best friends.
-We're best friends!
-We're best friends, you guys!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Here's how the game works.
Tina and I will take turns
facing our backs to the curtain.
Behind the curtain
will be something
neither of us have seen before.
It could be people, objects,
anything.
Taking turns, we'll have
45 seconds to try to get
the other person to guess
what's behind them.
Tina, if you don't mind,
I'll guess first.
-Okay.
-Let's get into position.
So, I -- Oh!
Oh, this thing moves.
Ohh!
-High-tech.
-[ Giggling ] Okay. Okay.
-Alright, now, Tina,
when the curtain opens,
you pick up that card.
And it has to be
the exact phrase.
You have to get me to guess.
-I have to get you
to say the phrases.
-The phrase that's on the card.
-Okay.
-Time starts
when you start talking.
Now let's open the curtain
and see what's behind me.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Okay, so...
Okay. This is a large --
a large monkey from the movies.
King Kong.
-Yes, yes.
And he's holding a giant version
of something that you eat
that's not a hamburger...
-A hot dog?
-Yes!
-And that thing is wearing
something that
fancy gentlemen wear.
-They're wearing a cap.
-Mr. Peanut wears one.
-Mr. Peanut wears a top hat.
-Yes! Yes!
-So it's King Kong eating
a hot dog with a top hat?
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I didn't realize
it's going to be real.
I thought it was
gonna be, like, a picture.
[ Laughter ]
-I had no idea.
-That guy's at work right now.
That's his job.
-He gets paid for that.
-That's his job.
-It is your turn to guess.
Let's rotate.
Here we go.
-Okay.
-This is high-tech, man.
It's big-budget, man.
-Ahh!
-This is big-budget stuff.
-Alright. Here we go.
Alright. Alright.
I'll be good at this.
Here we go. Ready?
Please open the curtain.
Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Famous movie scene about --
-"Gone with the Wind."
-No, a romantic comedy,
a romantic movie.
-Like top of the
Empire State Building?
-Whoopi Goldberg was in it.
-"Ghost." Pottery wheel.
-Except it's two famous,
uh, uh, aliens.
-Two famous aliens?
-Who's the most famous
movie alien?
-E.T.?
-Yes.
-Two E.T.s doing pottery.
-And it's not at the wintertime.
It is the --
-Summer.
-And where does the sun shine?
-On the beach.
-Yes, that's it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
-Wow.
-I mean, again --
There are two things.
One, you can't unsee that.
And then --
-And it's surprisingly sexy.
[ Laughter ]
-Please close that curtain!
Oh, my goodness.
Close that curtain, please!
I'm so sorry that
everyone had to see that
and America had to see that.
-Sorry, everybody.
-Alright. I'm up again.
Let's spin this.
-Whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo!
-Alright. Alright.
Alright.
-Okay.
-Please open the curtain.
Okay. Okay.
Alright. This is the, uh --
Okay.
It's a guy who's very jolly.
-Santa Claus.
-Yes.
And he's in a place where
white people enjoy themselves.
-Starbucks.
-White people enjoy themselves
until the Williams sisters
come along.
[ Laughter ]
-Wimbledon?
-Yeah, but that --
-Tennis. A tennis match.
-Yeah.
The place.
-A tennis court.
-Yes, and he's holding a thing
that everyone likes to joke down
but it's actually awesome.
-A Shake Weight.
[ Laughter ]
-You send it to people.
Like, you send it
to your grandma,
and it's like,
"Happy Mother's Day."
You can eat this.
-[ Laughs ] I've never sent
that to my grandma, ever.
-It looks like flowers,
but it's not flowers.
-Oh, it's edible arrangements!
-Yes!
-Oh, yes!
That's what I thought.
♪♪
Looks like he's gonna throw it.
-He's gonna whip it at us.
-He looks like he's gonna
whip it at me. It's weird.
Is that the same guy
that was the hot dog?
-Yeah.
Quick change.
-Unbelievable. Alright.
It's time for the final round.
Let's spin this.
-We win a car at
the end of this, right?
-Yes.
-Everyone wins a car.
-Everyone needs
to share one car.
It's a minivan.
-Okay.
Alright.
I'm getting ready for this.
Okay. Alright.
Uh, Alexa,
please open the curtain.
Please open the curtain.
[ Laughter ]
[ Tina laughs ]
-Okay. Uh...
Uh, uh, uh,
famous British invasion.
-The Beatles.
-Yes.
They're not in the beach,
but they are in the --
-The snow.
-Yes.
And they're using a toy
that was popular in the '50s
that you use your hips --
-"Howdy Doody." A hula hoop.
-Yes, that's correct!
The Beatles hula-hooping
in the snow!
Very nice. Beatles.
[ Laughs ]
That is fantastic right there.
That is as sexy as E.T. was,
just the opposite.
-It's the opposite.
-We always love to test out
new games with Tina,
So she and I are about
to try this new game
that our show thought of
called Box of Lies,
and it works like this.
Upstage are a bunch of boxes
containing objects neither
of us have seen before.
Taking turns, Tina and I
are going to select a box,
open it on our side
of the table,
out of view of the other person.
Once the object is
out of the box,
you look at your opponent
and you tell them
what's in the box.
You might be lying
or telling the truth.
[ Laughter ]
-Mm.
-Your opponent has
to guess which one
and say either lie or truth.
If you guess correctly,
you get a point.
If you guess wrong,
the other person gets a point.
First to three points wins.
Tina, as our guest, why don't
you pick the first box, please.
-I would love to.
Do you guys have a number?
-Five!
-Five? Okay.
-Four! Four!
-I heard five first.
-Okay.
Box number five.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
-I'm not gonna look,
so I can't see.
-Okay.
You guys got that?
Hello.
-Hi.
In my box...
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
That was a game
we tried once before.
It wasn't as funny.
-[ Laughs ]
-...was a kitchen colander
full of ping pong balls.
[ Laughter ]
I think that's a --
Oh, wait. I don't know.
'Cause you might be so good.
You might be telling the truth.
[ Laughs ] Gosh!
I'm gonna say it's a lie.
It is the ♪ truth ♪
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I knew it.
Alright. 1 point --
1 point Tina Fey.
Alright.
What number, everybody!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Three! Three!
Some guy was screaming three.
Alright. Here we go.
-It's very important to him.
-"It better be three!"
-[ Laughs ]
"You hear me on TV?
I said three."
-Oh, it's in the box.
Okay. Here we go.
They're all colanders
with ping pong balls.
-[ Laughs ]
-Your staff hates me.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
[ Both chuckle ]
-In my box...
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-...there was a sharp object.
-Okay.
-And it is one of those...
...bartender tools...
-Uh-huh.
...that have couple
useful things
and a couple things
that aren't useful.
Too many tools.
-Uh-huh.
-Swiss Army bartender knife.
[ Laughter ]
-Have you finished?
-Yes.
It's read. It's read.
[ Both laugh ]
-I think you are lying.
-Yes! You knew I am lying.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was an extendable fork,
which is really fun, yeah.
Oh, that's neat.
-Yeah, it is very sharp,
but Higgins had this --
He has like two of these
always on hand.
And when I'm having lunch,
he will eat lunch,
and he'll reach over
and have my lunch
and then I'll take it from him.
And then he'll pull
the second one out and...
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
May I have a number please?
-Seven!
-Oh, my gosh.
Seven.
This could be for the "ween."
-Oh, that's -- Okay.
"For the ween."
You could be the big weener.
-My box could be for the ween.
-Yeah.
That's what you're
trying to say. Okay.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
-Are you ready?
-Uh-huh.
-Mm-hmm. Yes.
-Hi.
-How goes it?
-It's going great.
Cool. Real cool.
-Great.
In my box...
was a very interesting
collectible.
-Mm.
-And I don't know...
super much about these things,
but I think it is
a Patrick Stewart doll.
It's a "Star Trek" doll.
It's a 12-inch "Star Trek" doll.
-In your box
is a 12-inch Patrick Stewart.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, you can lie
on this show.
[ Laughter ]
Gosh.
You're really clever.
So I'm gonna say
that you're...lying.
-[ Gasps ] I am lying!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh, she's so good!
I was like collectible.
It was so good.
The details are good.
Alright. Good. Number?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Nine?
Nine.
Number nine.
-Number nine.
-Alright.
Here we go.
Alright.
-Okay.
Make sure I don't see it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sighs ]
In my box...
-Oh, hello.
...is something I use every day.
[ Laughter ]
Something I have
in my bathroom.
What it is, is...
[ Laughter ]
...hair removal strips.
-Huh.
In a box?
-I-In the box.
-I think you're lying!
-I am not lying!
-Oh!
[ Applause ]
Alright.
[ Both shouting indistinctly ]
Whoever wins this, wins!
[ Chuckles ]
Oh, my gosh.
It doesn't matter if I move.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Coughs ]
Alright.
-Hi.
Fine weather we're having.
-You want to know
what's in my box?
-You know -- Hashtag.
[ Laughter ]
That's a good hashtag.
-Hasta-- [ Laughs ]
It's a cold Ballpark Frank
in a Ziploc bag.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-I've heard the urban legend.
In your box is a cold...
cold Ballpark Frank
in a Ziploc bag.
-Has grill marks on it.
[ Laughter ]
So someone grilled it...
put it in a Ziploc bag...
brought it to room temp
or colder,
place it in your box.
Okay.
Gosh. You're so tricky.
I don't know.
-[ Laughs ]
You're lying?
-I am telling the truth!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You are so good!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Shouts indistinctly ]
-We're about to play
a very suspenseful new game.
It is called True Confessions.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'll need two more players
to fill out this table.
The first one is a multiple
Emmy Award winner
and New York Times
best-selling author.
She was also my partner
on "Weekend Update"
at "Saturday Night Live."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Say hello to Tina Fey,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Now, Tina,
we'll need one more player.
-Yes.
-And you brought the best one
possible with you tonight.
She is a Golden Globe Award
winner.
She's also
a best-selling author.
She was also your partner
on "Weekend Update."
-[ Chuckles ]
-And on December 18th
of this year,
you guys are starring together
in a big, hilarious new movie
called "Sisters."
Here's our pal Amy Poehler,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Coming in hot!
♪♪
Come on. This is the best.
-Alright. Oh.
-Okay, everybody.
Here's how the game works.
In front of each of us
are two envelopes
containing confessions.
In one of the envelopes
is something that actually
happened to us in real life.
And in the second envelope
is a lie.
-Right.
-Okay?
Once you've read
your confession,
the other two people have
60 seconds to interrogate you.
And they have to guess
whether or not you've been lying
or telling the truth.
We'll take one turn each.
Tina, you'll go first.
Amy, which envelope
should Tina open?
-One or two.
-Hmm. Could be either one.
-[ Clears throat ]
Number one, please.
-Okay.
-Mm-hmm.
-By the way,
great to see you both.
-Yeah. It is great to see you.
-It's very nice to meet you.
[ Laughter ]
"I was once mistaken
for a prostitute in Monaco."
[ Laughter ]
-In Monaco?
-In Monaco.
The small country.
[ Laughter ]
-What year was this?
-Uh, 1992.
-How did you get to Monaco?
-I was on a trip with my cousin
visiting Europe.
-Just you and your cousin
in '92?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-You ever been to Europe
before then?
-Yes.
-And what were you wearing?
-I can tell you.
I was wearing a brown-and-white
polka-dot jumpsuit
that I had bought at --
-Were you in an ABBA tribute
band?
-I bought at Express.
-A brown-and-white polka dot?
-Brown-and-white --
It looked fantastic.
-Fantastic enough to be confused
as a prostitute?
-I don't see you in Monaco
either.
I don't see you there.
What were some sights that
you saw in Monaco?
-Yeah. What do you see so much,
you big seer?
-Okay.
I went to a casino there because
my cousin's from New Jersey
and we thought
it was gonna be fun
like an Atlantic City casino.
But it was like a creepy
James Bond casino,
and there was only like
40 people in the whole place.
-And what games
were they playing?
-Baccarat.
[ Laughter ]
-Burt Baccarat?
-Alright.
Burt Baccarat.
Uh, okay.
-Let me ask you this.
Were you ever a prostitute
in Monaco?
-No. Wait. We're out of time.
We're out of time now.
Here we go.
-Whoo!
-Now, Amy, we have to decide.
Amy, what did you think?
Truth or lie?
-Well, you know, it's very hard,
'cause I feel like I know
almost everything about Tina,
but I don't know her early years
as well.
But I'm gonna say
that was a lie.
-[ Laughs ]
-I also know a little bit
about you.
I don't -- I don't --
I could see you going to Express
and getting a jumpsuit.
[ Laughter ]
I can really see that.
I don't see you going
to Monaco either
and getting mistaken
for a prostitute.
Mm.
Well, do I tell you now?
-Yes.
-It is true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?!
-Yes. Yes.
-And then what happened?
How did...
-Again, we went to the casino.
Again, we thought it was
gonna be like bands playing
or whatever,
and it was just ice cold,
just weird Europeans
just quietly gambling.
We were the youngest people
there.
And my cousin is really pretty.
She's blond and really tall.
And I was just, like, with her,
like...
-You were doing that?
-That's how I walked then.
[ Laughter ]
-And we realized, like,
"Oh, this is not our scene."
And then this sort of, like,
older gentleman came over
and was like, "I would love
to buy the two of you dinner
in this restaurant here."
And it was like
a weird restaurant in the back.
And my cousin was like, "Yeah!
And I was like, "No.
I don't think this is
a good idea."
And it just sort of became clear
that the only possible
explanation for why
we would have been in there
is that we were prostitutes.
-And that is where
Tina met her husband.
-Yes.
-It's a great story.
It's a fantastic story.
It's beautiful.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright. It's my turn.
Which envelope should I open?
Tina?
-Um, I'm gonna say number two
'cause poop.
[ Laughter ]
That's not funny.
-Come on. That's funny.
Get out of here. Oh!
-Hey, kids. That's funny.
-Alright.
-Oh! I spilled the coffee.
-No. It's alright. Don't...
-Shoot.
Our props.
-Poop. Poop.
Okay.
-Our props! Our props!
Our cigarettes!
[ Laughter ]
-No one believes that they're
really smoking anyway.
Here we go.
"In college, my friend and I
were robbed by a drug dealer
with a sawed-off shotgun."
[ Laughter ]
-First of all,
what college did you go to?
[ Laughter ]
-Clown College.
Uh, I went to the College
of St. Rose in Albany, New York.
-What was your friend's name?
Uh, Sean.
-That's not true.
You only have one friend.
His name is Gerard.
[ Laughter ]
-It wasn't Gerard.
-Yeah. That's suspicious.
-Alright.
-This guy's name was Sean.
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah.
-And, um --
How did you know
he was a drug dealer?
-Uh, I didn't.
I didn't know
he was a drug dealer.
I was actually going
to his house
'cause he was gonna give me
a ride to the mall.
-Uh-huh.
-So I was just waiting in his
living room for him to come out.
He had some business
to take care of.
-And how had you met
this person?
-He's a friend of another friend
that I went to college with.
-Hey, you got kids.
[ Laughter ]
-You're the tough cop?
Yeah. Yes, I got kids.
-You ever think about them
when you go to buy drugs?
[ Laughter ]
-It wasn't --
I wasn't buying drugs.
-Well, it sounds like you were.
-I was not.
-These cigarettes
are really smoky.
-I spilled the coffee
everywhere.
Okay.
-I think it's...a lie.
-I think it's true,
and you did a bad job of
telling the story on purpose.
-Ah!
I still think it's a lie.
-Okay, I'm gonna say true
but you pretended
like it was fake.
And you're gonna say?
-I'll say fake just
so we have an option.
-Okay.
-Thank you.
It is the truth.
-Ah!
-It happened to me in -- Yeah.
[ Applause ]
It was a weird thing.
I didn't know my friend
was a drug dealer.
I went over 'cause he was gonna
give me a ride to the mall.
And I go and I was waiting
for this ride.
He goes, "I just got
to talk to my friend.
I'll be out in two seconds."
I go, "Cool."
Then this dude came out
with a duffel bag.
They got in a fight, and he
came in with a duffel bag,
pulled out a shotgun,
pointed at me,
and told me to get
on the ground.
And I was like,
"What's going on?"
-"In 25 years,
I'm gonna be very important!"
-"What is going on?"
And then he left and took off.
I go to my friend,
"What was that all about?
He goes, "Sorry, dude.
It was a drug dealer,"
or something like that.
He goes, "I don't want
to get into it now."
I go, "Oh my God. Alright.
I'm gonna go home.
I mean, we're not gonna go
to the mall?"
He goes, "No, we can't,
because that guy stole my car."
So we ended up not going
to the mall either.
That was a real bummer.
-Mall bummer.
Alright.
Here we go.
Amy, you are up.
-[ Clears throat ]
-You pick.
-Oh, yeah. Okay.
I'll pick.
Uh, I'm gonna say number one
'cause you guys are number one.
-Thanks, dude.
-Nice.
-So are you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
"I once helped Yoko Ono
cross the street."
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Alright, alright.
Wait a second.
-Aw.
I find that extremely plausible.
-Okay.
-I don't know if she needs help
crossing the street.
That's the only reason why...
-That's true.
She's fit.
-She's perfectly fine.
-What street was it?
-I'd love to hear a question.
-What street?
[ Laughter ]
-It was 66th.
Like, it was around
the Phillips Club area.
-Phillips Club.
I don't know what that means.
It was -- I don't know.
Upper West Side?
-What do you do in those clubs?
-You look for Phillips.
[ Laughter ]
-She knows the Upper West Side.
She lives over there, right?
She owns a part of Central Park.
-Yoko does.
She knows her way around.
-You, though.
What was Yoko wearing?
-She was wearing a black --
like, a jacket
and a jaunty black hat
and, like, tiny black jeans.
-Was she wearing a polka-dot
jumpsuit from Express?
Oh, really?
Did you know Yoko Ono?
What'd you say to her?
-I didn't know it was her.
But she was in the middle
of the street,
and she was kind of, like,
what I thought was disoriented.
And I was like, "Ma'am,
are you okay?"
And then I realized
it was Yoko Ono.
And so I just said, like --
I-I kind of just, like, led her
to the other side of the street.
-Really?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And what did she say to you?
-She was standing
in the middle of the street,
and maybe it was an art project,
but I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-When was this?
-This was like three years ago.
Alright. Three years ago.
Okay. Alright.
We're out of time.
This is a toughie, man.
-It's funny, because I feel
like it could be a lie.
It could be the opposite
of what you did.
It could be a lie
that she's sold very, very well.
-Exactly.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
But I think that you're
a very nice person.
You would help someone
cross the street.
But also, as a fan of art,
I think you would just let
the piece play out.
So...
-That means a lot to me.
-Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
-Thank you.
I am such a fan of art. Oh!
-Fan of art. Oh.
-I think of you all the time
at the galleries.
At the Phillips Club.
You're always at the
Phillips Club, looking at art.
[ Laughter ]
"Is Art here?"
"No, just Phillips only."
I'm gonna say --
I'm gonna say that is a lie.
-I'm gonna agree.
I think it's a lie.
-Yeah. That's a bald-faced lie.
-Well, congratulations.
It's a lie.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You tried to fake me out
with the art thing!